c'est une tradition ancestrale pendant
la saison de la chasse des hommes et
leur faut qu'on se retrouvent entre eux
à l'ombre d'un arbre en plein désert
[Musique]
c'est autant l'occasion de passer du bon
temps entre hommes que de lâcher les
prédateurs poursuite d'une 3 c'est ainsi
que cheikh fayçal occupe ses temps
libres depuis son enfance
[Musique]
c'était une façon de se nourrir il ya
très longtemps à l'époque des nomades in
modique puis c'est devenu le loisir et
le sport de l'élite
un bios pour les élites mais les temps
changent
bien qu un faucon exceptionnel puisse se
rendre jusqu'à 100000 dollars le sport
n'est plus réservée khalili
m
une paire de son essence déplore le che
sud et à tous égaux
autre signe des temps en arabie saoudite
les formes de divertissement se
multiplient pour les masses qui les
consomment de façon quasi boulimique
musique pop danse pour les enfants jeux
d'adressé typique d'une fête foraine
djeddah convie ce soir ses habitants
dans ce que les organisateurs appellent
le petit paris
on essaie n'importe qui ici tout ce
qu'on trouve ailleurs
les gens n'ont donc pas besoin de
voyager notre thème si c'était on vous
offre paris
ce ne sont pas les répliques de la tour
eiffel ou de l'arc de triomphe qui sont
extraordinaires ici mais plutôt le
simple fait de voir garçons et filles
hommes femmes et enfants s'entremêler de
façon désinvolte
[Musique]
chaque semaine il y à des événements
différents ici à jeddah cette semaine il
y en a quatre
ça ne s'était jamais vu en arabie
saoudite c'est une industrie en plein
essor et ça plaît beaucoup aux gens ils
s'amusent
l'arabie saoudite est avide de nouvelles
distraction sous le coup d'un décret
royal le royaume a mis en place une
autorité général du divertissement
tous les jours un concert un opéra une
fois publiques et bientôt des cinémas
autant de forme de distraction et
d'activités culturelles étaient
interdites il ya un an
[Musique]
et
les autorités qui sanctionne ses
activités s'assure que certains
paramètres soient respectés
non les haut parleurs ne font pas défaut
mais pour les prochaines minutes
deschamps n'a pas le choix il sera seul
à pouvoir profiter de sa performance
[Musique]
c'est maintenant l'heure de la prière
pour les musulmans
et on doit observer le silence on était
la musique
[Musique]
peu importe ce qu'on fait on respecte
les limites
on ne va pas à l'encontre de notre
religion ni de notre culture
alors ce qu'on fait acceptable pour
beaucoup de gens
c'est là
ça m'embête pas cette jeunesse qui prend
plaisir à tester ces nouvelles libertés
plus en plus les jeunes femmes
délaissent le voile
certaines se permettent une plus grande
créativité dans l'interprétation de
skins tenue mode est un des éléments
clés de ces réformes sociales un retour
vers ce que le prince héritier mohammed
bin salman a décrit comme un islam
modéré ça veut dire entre autres que la
commission pour la promotion de la vertu
et la prévention des vices la fameuse
police religieuse dans les quartiers
généraux sont juste derrière moi a été
privé de la majorité de ses pouvoirs
les policiers ne peuvent plus par
exemple arrêté une femme qui choisit de
ne pas porter de voile ou même la
traditionnelle abaya noire comme celle
ci c'est un choix personnel a déclaré le
prince héritier récemment ce n'est pas
prescrit par la loi
ghonim le shérif c'est ce qu'il a dit en
entrevue à l'émission sixty minutes de
cbs
à la veille de son voyage aux etats-unis
qui visent à vendre son plan de réforme
mais pour certains des principaux
intéressés qui se conforme tant bien que
mal à leur nouveau rôle diminuer la
pilule passe mal
voyez comme celui-ci mort donne au
passage 2 me couvrir
et un de ses collègues qui se dit
pourtant heureux des récents changements
tient un discours opposé au prince
héritier on ne renie pas ses convictions
religieuses aussi vite consignes décret
règle générale c'est mieux de se méfier
du regard des autres et de chercher à
l'éviter il faut s'en cacher la charia
ordonne à la femme de se couvrir la tête
et le visage cela la protège aux yeux de
dieu parce qu'au fond c'est la seule
chose sincère à faire et si elle ne
respecte pas ce qui devrait être sa
croyance c'est son air en privé loin des
caméras beaucoup de saoudiens exprime
francs d accord avec la volonté du
prince de ramener l'arabie saoudite est
ce qu'il décrit comme un islam modéré
peut on la témérité de ce prince de
critiquer ouvertement la mise en oeuvre
des réformes sociales
de ses affaires et exalté you were c'est
une nouvelle ère en arabie saoudite cet
excitant il faut qu'on change
tu
[Musique]
changé mais pas trop et pas trop vite
dit certain qu'ils se sentent bousculés
ils n'ont pas demandé ces
transformations qu'ils subissent avec
une profonde appréhension qu'elle vienne
provoquer dans le royaume
ultraconservateur
un véritable choc sismique
[Musique]